from all of us down here in Mission
Control welcome to
space the Russians always knocked three
times I think it's just a
[Applause]
Superstition down to G
Park listening to the wind of
change wow I mean I seen pictures but
this is we don't talk politics here we
are
[Music]
one hey guys wait a minute what the hell
is going on down there wa we got to get
out now guys get out oh my
God
[Music]
you sent you
read War has broken out
below and we were told to take the
ISS by any means necessary if we got
orders from our government to take
control what do you suggest we do now
did you ever
we could CL the Russians got the same
orders as
us and they just struck first struck
[Music]
first M we're evolved
species
w